oh this is pretty I like their pockets
girl that's good you can put like little
surprises those snacks in there my dress
is gonna be going like this by the end
of the night what you gonna put in there
ah snacks yeah alcohol will cheese's
jeez it's yes I know
there you go so I guess the night goes
on you need whatever you want it's gonna
get bigger and bigger but I put a burger
in there you know can we talk about this
you cannot leave the Big Bang Theory
like it the show needs to keep on going
on and on and on we cannot stop I don't
want to leave either it's like
everyone's saying the same thing it's so
sweet at 12 years I know we I don't want
to leave I don't wanna leave I said it I
don't want to leave I know
can we just what do we do let's just you
know can we just like protests there's
how we keep going there's a lot of
reruns
yes it's gonna live on for a long time
well we can always that ago for a year
and then have a reboot after a year
everyone's rebooting we might as well do
it like a year one year I'm fine fine
with that I know I will live forever I'm
with you I know are you guys gonna be
like super sad yes I was laughing I was
like how are we gonna shoot the last
episode I was hoping we're gonna pre
shoot a lot of it cuz I think they're
gonna be a lot of tears because they
have them not tell you it's the last one
movement oh and then just in my yeah and
then nobody will really know and it'll
just be the last one it's gonna be it's
gonna be tough it's been a lot of years
a lot of emotions and we I love our crew
I just love all the people that were
with every day so you know all good
things come to an end everybody still
hang out after yes everyone is still
madly in love with each other we're all
okay with the choice and I don't know we
just been we've grown up together so
it's a dolt decision I love it what's
the most painful thing about this dress
it looks really comfortable
I have pockets this is Monique Lhullier
and I am so thrilled right now I am
comfortable I feel it's about the
pockets
I'm just happy with that there you go I
love it not worried about my hair it's
all very relaxed because this doesn't
usually happen mine is not so relaxed so
I'm gonna like your dress I totally
understand yeah I bet trust me I've been
there too
well congratulations thank you
[Music]